la sologne n'est certainement pas la
région du monde où il y a le plus
d'heures qui des mets ici à quelques
kilomètres de contre il n'y en a 35
milles en culture et parmi elles souvent
méconnu des orchidées à parfum il ya des
vendeurs dans la nature non hybride et
qui émettent un parfum elles émettent un
parfum pour attirer un insecte certes
mais quel est véritablement le parfum
d'une fleur d'orchidée est-il commun à
toutes les espèces ou bien multiples en
fait tout dépend de ses parents l'un des
parents de l'anssi diom chéri baby c'est
un nom si diom donc botanique
ornithorynque homme qui aimait ce parfum
parce qu'il a une toute petite fleur et
pour que l'insecte pollinisateur puisse
le trouver
il aimait un parfum ça attire l'insecte
il aimait le parfum et il aimait aussi
des petites gouttelettes sur la tige des
petites bouteilles qui sont archi sucre
et donc ils attirent l'insecte par le
parfum et par le sucre et si l'on s'y
diom chéri bibi offre un parfum nous
faire rêver ce n'est pas toujours le cas
certaines fleuron des odeurs plutôt
désagréable mais qui présente un certain
intérêt pour elle sans doute que
l'insecte qui peut polliniser solidaris
ça un sac qui va sur les poissons morts
donc elle émet le même parfum
ici il y a cinq cents espèces
d'orchidées et les fragrances les plus
variés mais pour les parfums des
asperges et de fraises
ce sont les serres d'à côté